en el último vídeo hable acerca de las
hojas de balance personal y de lo que
significa la insolvencia y la falta de
liquidez y si lo entendiste creo que ya
estamos listos para meternos a ver cómo
se ven las hojas de balance de uno de
estos bancos que se encuentran en
problemas no vamos a ver los detalles
solo el panorama en general que es lo
que realmente importa entonces
esencialmente estos bancos tienen un
montón de activos y bueno voy a hablar
de los bancos de una forma muy general
son ambos bancos comerciales y de
inversión en el próximo vídeo te diré la
diferencia entre ambos y lo que
significa regulación y trabajo y un
montón de cosas pero por el momento
pensemos en lo que significa una hoja de
balance para un banco entonces activos y
bueno nada más me voy a poner a inventar
aquí algunas cosas pero bueno digamos
que el banco tiene un billón de pesos
en la forma de bonos del gobierno
entonces nada más lo estoy inventando
espero
o sea podría haber un montón de
distintas formas de tener activos pero
bueno estamos escogiendo estas y tiene
10 billones de pesos en bonos
corporativos de corporaciones triple-a
estas son compañías muy confiables muy
solventes que tienen un flujo de
efectivo buenísimo y hay una
probabilidad de que no paguen sus
préstamos a tiempo super baja
y que es un bono pues los bonos
simplemente son préstamos a otras
entidades si tú me presta dinero yo te
puedo dar un papelito que diga yo te
debo a ti lo que sea o sea diez pesos y
a eso le podemos llamar un bono de
salman un millón de pesos de bono y
bonos del gobierno significa que el
gobierno me debe a mí un billón de pesos
y mientras no los pague me va a pagar
intereses y lo mismo pasa para estas
corporaciones o sea entre todas estas
corporaciones que me hayan dado sus
bonos me deben 10 billones de pesos y
mientras tanto van a pagar mi intereses
y eso es lo que es o sea los activos son
cualquier cosa que me vaya a
proporcionar un beneficio económico en
el futuro y estos bonos si tienen un
valor económico en el futuro tienen el
valor de los pagos de los intereses más
los 10 billones de pesos que me van a
pagar eventualmente si es que me los
pagan pero bueno ese no es el problema
ahorita el verdadero problema aquí es
que también tenemos un activo muy
apestoso y bueno déjame antes agregó
otros activos
para que veas que realmente es super
apestoso y horrendo
digamos que tengo otro grupo de activos
no sé digamos que son 10 billones de
pesos
en hipotecas comerciales
10 billones
hipotecas comerciales
o sea yo le presto dinero a alguna
compañía para que compre tierra o
siempre la tierra o compren edificios
que le van a rentar a otras personas que
al final de cuentas sigue siendo un
préstamo a alguien más y como tal es un
activo porque estas compañías me van a
pagar intereses y eventualmente me van a
regresar lo que les preste ahora si
vamos al meollo del asunto digamos que
vamos a tengo 21 billones ahorita vamos
a ponerle 4 billones para que sean 25
millones en total
y digamos que son 4 billones en cd o
residenciales sede o de obligaciones de
deuda colateralizada
que ya hice un vídeo sobre esto pero voy
a hacer un repaso rápido los cds son
instrumentos derivativos y yo sé que
suena muy complicado pero solo quiere
decir que se derivan de otro instrumento
lo cual ya es una muy mala señal o sea
el mal olor está empezando a salir de
esta parte de la hoja de balance que es
lo que significa esto derivado pues
tomas un montón de hipotecas lo dibujo
aquí por acá
estas son hipotecas sobre casas
tal vez tomas un millón de ellas y las
agrupa y terminas con un título de
garantía hipotecaria y eso lo único que
significa es un préstamo a un gran
número de personas y los pones todos
juntos para poder manejarlo mejor darle
propiedades estadísticas porque si se lo
prestas a una sola persona es difícil de
vender pero si se lo prestas a un boche
de personas se convierte en algo que
puedes intercambiar con otras personas
porque lo podemos comprender mejor en
promedio nada más el 8 por ciento de las
personas no va a pagar sus dedos a
tiempo pero ese no es el medio del
asunto ya tengo un vídeo sobre esto los
cd os obligaciones de deuda
colateralizada son derivados de los
títulos de garantía hipotecaria y por
eso se les llama instrumentos derivados
lo que son estos deseos es que tomás
estos títulos con garantía hipotecaria
que son préstamos a personas en algún
lugar del país y las partes en francas
las partes en franjas luego con mucho
más detalle en otros vídeos
y dices ok esta franja de los cedros va
a obtener los primeros pagos de las
hipotecas y todos van a ir directamente
aquí a los siguientes pagos van a ir a
esta franja y los últimos pagos van a ir
a la franja de hasta arriba aunque ya
esta franja le llaman también franja de
capital
y esta franja va a quedarse con todo lo
que quede ok si todo el mundo paga se
quedan con mucho dinero pero si no si
era una persona incumple en sus pagos y
deja de pagar estos pagan el pato ok
entonces esa franja se está quedando con
todo el riesgo que estas franjas lo
están pasando el riesgo a la franja de
arriba y van a uso de franjas nada más
una palabra pero a cambio de todo ese
riesgo esta franja va a obtener un
rendimiento más alto esta persona podría
tener un 6 por ciento está un 7 por
ciento y esta franja que obtiene el 12
por ciento de su dinero y este es otra
cosa interesante como esta persona
obtiene su dinero con mucha seguridad la
compañía que se dedica a poner la
calificación crediticia seguro le pone
una triple a ya esta franja una doble a
estoy inventando esto espero y a esta
franja le van a poner seguro una pésima
calificación porque tiene mucho riesgo y
por lo tanto nadie va a querer comprarla
entonces la persona que construyó todo
éste cedió y vendió estas franjas al
mercado
por cierto este proceso se llama
securitización y bueno estás creando
títulos sobre estos activos que le
vendes a otras personas no sé tal vez
los chinos pero las personas solo
quieren comprar estas franjas entonces
los bancos tienen que averiguar qué
hacer con esta franja que es la franja
apestosa capital y algunos simplemente
lo dejan en su hoja de balance y dice no
parece que si van a pagar más del 90 por
ciento las hipotecas y tenemos un muy
buen rendimiento en esto entonces vamos
a quedarnos con la con esta franja y
bueno eso es lo que estos cds
residenciales son
y ahí está el meollo del asunto porque
no son cualquier asedios no son los
triples para dejarlo claro
estos son los apestosos entonces bueno
en este ejemplo esta es la parte de los
activos veamos ahora qué pasa con los
pasivos
entonces pasivos
pasivos y digamos que tiene un montón de
préstamos digamos que tiene el préstamo
con una deuda de 10 billones de pesos
y déjame lo pongo un poco de efectivo
aquí en los activos un banco siempre
necesita tener un poco de efectivo en
caso de que alguien quiera su dinero en
ese momento y bueno esto es en el caso
de los bancos comerciales pero digamos
que tiene efectivo para cualquier
necesidad de liquidez que se presente y
bueno también tiene un préstamo b en el
cual digamos que debe 10 billones de
pesos y tiene un tercer préstamo el
préstamo sé
para hacerlo interesante vamos a ponerle
que debe 3 billones de pesos y entonces
en este ejemplo aquí si asumimos que
todos estos activos y todos estos
pasivos están bien cuál es el capital de
este banco y bueno si es una empresa que
cotiza en la bolsa cual es el capital de
los dueños de las acciones calculemos lo
su capital
y bueno sus activos son 21 41 26
billones de pesos ok y sus pasivos son
23 billones entonces el capital es 26
billones menos 23 billones y nos quedan
3 billones de pesos de capital
y pongámoslo claro que es lo que es este
capital digamos que esta es una compañía
que cotiza en la bolsa y tú tienes una
acción de esta compañía entonces lo que
tienes es una acción sobre este capital
llamémosle es jacob ya este banco no
saben que no me gusta mejor nada más
dejémoslo en banco a
y digamos que el banco tiene
bankoa
tiene no sé
tiene 500.000 millones de acciones
ok si vas a la parte de finanzas de
yahoo y buscas cuántas acciones tiene el
banco ahora te dice que tiene 500 mil
millones de acciones
entonces
el valor libro de cada una de estas
acciones debería ser 3 billones de
capital según esta hoja de balance y por
eso le llaman valor libro porque a la
hoja de balance le llamamos libro de la
compañía entonces deberíamos de dividir
estos tres billones entre los 500 mil
millones entonces el valor libro de cada
acción debe ser seis pesos ok de valor
capital por acción y eso es algo muy
importante un montón de personas cree
que si una acción se va a cero
quiere decir que puedes comprar la
compañía por nada y eso no es cierto eso
sólo quiere decir que el capital de la
compañía vale cero nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo